لا أعرف من أين أتت ، لكنني
حصلت على هذه الفكرة ، كان لدي هذه الرؤية الكاملة ، يمكنني
أن أرى كل شيء وهو شريط
السقاة ثم الاختلاط والتشويش والاهتزاز
، لكن لا يوجد كحول
أتذكر دائمًا أن الناس جاءوا في الحال إلى حد
كبير  الخفاش عندما
فتحنا الباب - كان لدي كل هذا الخوف من
أننا سنفتح الباب وضع علامة
الخروج.
والمخاطرين ، يبدو الأمر كما لو
لم ينجح الأمر ، فما هو أسوأ
ما سيحدث عندما بدأنا
في ابتكار القائمة التي
أردتها من المكونات الصحية التي كنت أرغب في الحصول على
العديد من المكونات الطازجة والمحلية قدر المستطاع ،
لكنني أيضًا أردت أن تكون المشروبات كذلك
الحنين إلى الماضي في ذهني كنت أفكر
فيه على أنه نسخة حديثة من
نافورة الصودا القديمة ،
لذا فإن المشروبات الأولى التي توصلنا إليها
كانت ريكي وهي حبوب ليما
وعصير الليمون ، ثم فوسفات الفوسفات
هو ما اعتادوا تقديمه في القديم
فاش  نوافير الصودا المؤينة قبل أن يكون
حامض الستريك شيئًا كبيرًا يضيفون
الفوسفات ، يمكنك الذهاب إلى
نافورة الصودا القديمة والحصول على
مثل الكرز أو فوسفات الشوكولاتة الذي
يأتي إليه هذا الرجل ورأى الفوسفات الذي قال إن
جدتي اعتادت إحضارها لي في
الكنيسة كل يوم أحد مع وعد
بإمكانية الحصول على فوسفات الشوكولاتة من
هذه الصيدلية بعد الكنيسة ، قلت إنني
سأخلق طفولتك أمامك
[موسيقى]